in November 2022 the Ontario College of
psychologists ordered Jordan Peterson to
complete a quote education or remedial
program regarding professionalism and
public statements end quote comrade
Peterson refused to be re-educated and
appealed in court
[Music]
last week three judges unanimously
rejected his appeal and ordered him to
pay the college twenty five thousand
dollars the way Jordan's been treated
from day one and the way he's being
treated now is highly symptomatic of
where we are as a culture this was
especially apparent when he first became
a public figure did you notice that the
question they used most often to try and
attack him was well most of your
audience are men so blah blah blah I
wasn't specifically aiming this message
at young men to begin with it just kind
of turned out that way and it's mostly
you admit it's mostly men listening I
mean it is your audience is amazing well
it's about 80 on on YouTube which is a
YouTube is a male domain primarily you
can only ask that question if you
believe there's something wrong with men
no one attacks makeup brands because the
majority of their customers are women
the fact is a powerful minority want men
to be weak incompetent and feeble they
don't understand that in doing so
they're sowing the seeds of their own
and our entire society's downfall they
attempt to undermine subvertent
problematize healthy masculinity is
guaranteed to backfire and already is
backfiring first it makes us vulnerable
to other cultures which raise men to be
strong and capable second suppressing
healthy masculinity only leads to other
mostly unhealthy expressions of
masculinity have you noticed that
there's been an explosion in men going
to the gym specifically to look buff
this is a largely Western phenomenon
Informer Soviet countries where I go
regularly gyms are full of two groups of
people young women who want to stay in
shape and middle-aged guys with beer
bellies trying to save off a heart
attack even in the gym buff guys are a
tiny minority this isn't a comment on
the benefits or otherwise of men lifting
weights just an observation that in
cultures where healthy masculinity is
not demonized men don't have to look for
acceptable ways of expressing it but
displaced masculinity can also come out
in unhealthy ways too this is where
Jordan came in he reminded men what
being Man actually means responsibility
Duty sacrifice courage and honor and for
this he was roundly attacked by
journalists mainly female ones as being
divisive and toxic etc for telling men
to be better Jordan isn't perfect no one
is but his message was essential
especially for men and they're trying to
ruin his career for it
foreign